Lori and Michael have been dating for
over a year now if he were to ask to
marry her would you approve
ment
Steve Harvey doesn't just hand out
blessings and if daughter Lori Harvey
and Michael B Jordan ever decide to tie
the knot he's gonna need to take the
edge off okay well I ain't mad at that
y'all ain't mad and a sneak peek of the
comedian's interview on Friday's episode
of today with Hoda and Jenna Steve plays
a game of sip or spill the rules answer
the question truthfully or take a drink
you know I think okay this is the game
right right but it wasn't man with Lori
and Michael's romance showing no signs
of slowing down Hoda takes the game to
the next level or Michael have been
dating for over a year now if he were to
ask to marry her would you approve
cool
oh man
you know I've given away two daughters
man I got four
that's a really hard one yeah while the
game is called sip or Spill The Family
Feud host does a little of both I would
have to say so far
um
yeah yeah no no no oh man
foreign
this moment follows Ellen DeGeneres
putting Steve on the spot in January
I've never seen that picture before
uncomfortable with that picture right
there I'm not really feeling that
picture while Steve might be
uncomfortable with the couple's PDA he
admits it's hard not to be impressed by
the Black Panther star I saw him kind of
pulling for him but at the same time I'm
just I got my eye on him you know I
can't whoop him but if he ever turn
around I'm Gonna Knock his ass out Lori
and Michael celebrated their one year
anniversary in November oh man it's like
I'm trying to knock this mile so hard
right now the couple also shared their
sweet Valentine's Day moments to
Instagram that's the 35 year old actor
gifting his leading lady with flowers
cuddling up alongside her and planting a
big old kiss on her while she sips
champagne and when Etsy sat down with
the just Mercy star last year he opened
up about their love what is Michael B
Jordan find very sexy
um that's a good one uh I think it's
I think it's sense of humor I think you
know the ability to laugh you know that
infectious feeling I think is I think is
really really sexy so a smile a nice
smile and a laugh and a sense of humor
is uh is really sexy to me well I see
why you found who you found then because
she has all of those all those things
absolutely actually very funny a lot of
people don't know that about it yeah
she's really funny yeah
[Music]